kanigo is an AI teaching assistant built
by Khan Academy and designed to help all
students learn
conmigo has a fun and eccentric
personality and is always willing and
able to be your creative co-pilot
conveigo is not just for students
teachers can use conmigo too by toggling
from student mode to teacher mode once
in teacher mode con mego transforms into
the teaching assistant you've always
wanted
conmigo is extremely engaging and very
knowledgeable it's like having an
experienced Master teacher in your
pocket that has a strong understanding
of pedagogical principles
kanmigo has many exciting features that
support teachers and this video will
showcase ways teachers can use conmigo
to get a class snapshot of their class
to ensure students are using conmigo
with Fidelity and receiving the support
necessary for them to be successful
class snapshot is a quick overview of
how students are performing in class on
Khan Academy
it highlights key areas such as recent
activity course Mastery progress
assignments and skill development by
reviewing the class snapshot that
convigo provides teachers can gain
insight into students learning and
identify areas where they may need
additional support or encouragement
this snapshot will help you tailor your
teaching approach to better meet the
needs of your students and ensure
they're on track to achieve their
learning goals
by integrating conmico into classroom
routines teachers will be able to take
the ideas and suggestions provided by
conmigo and adapt them into classroom
specific content considering factors
like student needs learning goals and
available resources
incorporating conmigo into the classroom
is going to be a game changer for
teachers
conmigo's insights and suggestions are
going to enhance classroom learning and
make teachers lives Easier by saving
them time so they'll have the ability to
focus on what's important they are
students
let's get a class snapshot of how my
students are progressing in their
Algebra 1 course
con Nigo could you please give me a
class snapshot of my algebra 1 students
we'll hit one click of the button
conmigo can give me a high level
overview of my students performance for
the past seven days
conmigo then gives me the option to see
which students should be celebrated for
working on their assignments
it'll give me a list of students who are
above 25 on their course Mastery goal it
allows me to group my class into three
groups based on their progress for the
week and it also lets me see who needs a
check-in about their skills progress for
that week now I know I love to celebrate
my students and that's one of my
favorite things so that's the one that
I'm going to select
and as much as I love celebrating my
students conmigo knows it's important to
look at all of my students especially
the ones who may be struggling or stuck
so kamiko suggests that I view my
students assignment scores report and
conmigo also provides the link for me so
it's easily accessible
I noticed that several of my students
are struggling with solving systems of
equations which honestly is not my
favorite thing to teach but not to worry
I have my teaching assistant
you can chat with conmigo anytime while
you're logged into your Khan Academy
account it can help you navigate the
site find engaging content for your
students and can even give you tips on
teaching
conmigo what should the objectives for
be for systems of equations and can you
recommend an activity for my students
wonderful
conmigo can you provide a video that I
can assign to my students for this
lesson
perfect thank you for providing the link
also conmigo thank you
this is great and from the screen I can
easily assign this lesson to my students
thanks conmigo
one last thing
looking at my students report I noticed
that Jason is really struggling and you
did give me a heads up about that so I
was wondering could you please help me
draft a progress report for him that I
can send home to his family this is
great camigo thank you actually conmigo
Jason's mom speaks Spanish could you
please translate this letter for me this
is wonderful thank you so much conmigo
conmigo's insights and suggestions are
going to enhance classroom learning and
make teachers lives Easier by saving
them time so they'll have the ability to
focus on what's important their students
thank you so much conmigo
foreign